hey 42 here millions of people around
the world have at least one cherished
childhood memory
involving a Walt Disney film or
character the appeal is simply universal
and somewhere in the massive catalog of
Disney branded works there's a story for
you as well
one that can inspire you warm your heart
make you laugh or just remind you not to
forget to wish upon a star once in a
while but as for the legendary man
behind the entertainment powerhouse
there's plenty more to him and the
company that he created than meets the
eye here are some surprising facts you
may not already know about Walt Disney
and the global brands that he created
Walt Disney was born in 1901 as the
fourth of five children in a Chicago
home built by his father's own two hands
it was this same self-made attitude
which would carry Walt through all of
the successes and setbacks during his
life despite his creative genius Walt
Disney never had any knack for business
according to his brother Roy a fact that
would return to haunt him throughout his
career Walt Disney Animation Studios
wasn't actually Disney's first business
venture in 1919 after a brief stint in
France with the Red Cross
Walt moved to Kansas City Missouri where
he developed his passion for art by
taking a job as a newspaper artist
within the next two years he began
investigating sell animation and found
an animation studio where he produced
the laugh-o-gram series of cartoons by
1923 the studio was forced to declare
bankruptcy
proving that failure is just another
twist on the path to success
perseverance is key my friends Disney
was also a trendsetter in the realm of
television creating popular children's
programming like Zorro and Davy Crockett
as well as the Mickey Mouse Club which
born the Mouseketeers and saw a modern
revival in the early 90s Ryan Gosling
Britney Spears and Justin Timberlake are
all former members of the Mouseketeers
just to name a few contemporary
celebrities who have had their early
careers propelled by Disney Walt Disney
wasn't afraid to get involved with
political issues stirring controversy
one of the founders of the
anti-communist group motion picture
Alliance for the preservation of
American ideals he also produced many
pieces of animated propaganda during
World War two ranging from anti-hitler
pieces to encouraging the timely payment
of taxes in order to bolster the war
effort however Disney firmly stated that
outside of very specific instances
during wartime
he and his team quote-unquote worked
hard to see that nothing of that sort
creeps in the quality control folks at
Disney can be ruthless part of your
world was almost caught from the Little
Mermaid and can you feel a love tonight
was almost removed from The Lion King
but Elton John insisted that it was kept
in the film Beyonce refused to audition
for the role of Princess Tiana and
simply expected to be offered the role
she lost the role to her dream girls
co-star Annie Curtin only rose the
people who voiced Minnie and Mickey
Mouse were married in real life when
Walt Disney was given an Oscar for Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs it was
presented to him as one normal-sized
statuette and seven miniature Oscars
before Disney created the famous Mouse
mascot
he had Oswald the Lucky Rabbit but for
Walt
Oswald was anything but lucky after
being hired by Universal in 1927 to
develop the character and using Oswald
for two years in 26 different cartoons
Disney discovered that he didn't
actually retain any rights to the
character as an asset for use in his own
works ownership of Oswald was completely
usurped by another party shortly
thereafter so well proceeded to conceive
a new character which would be wholly
his a happy-go-lucky steamboat piloting
Mouse by the name of Mickey almost
eighty years later
Oswald would joined his younger brother
under the Walt Disney Animation Studios
banner a tireless worker Walt Disney was
the creative force driving the teams
behind more than 600 cartoons both
feature-length and short form as ranked
by Forbes the Disney brand is the
eleventh most valuable brand in the war
as of 2015 it is also the most valuable
brand in the leisure industry Disneyland
was a passion project for Walt's
namesake who dreamed of an adil ik place
for wholesome family fun where children
could be themselves and adults could be
kids again it wasn't to be just another
amusement park with a celebration of mid
twentieth century America and a magical
place where dreams could come true
it's open to the public on July the 17th
1955 the site where the park was built
in Anaheim California was formerly an
orange grove
nestled in the heart of Disneyland's new
orleans square is a secretive Club
Disney created for VIPs and discerning
visitors to the park called club 33
inspired by the private VIP lounges he
visited at the 1964 World's Fair
becoming a member of the club is an
appropriately exclusive process
requiring a written letter of inquiry
which places you on a waiting list for
an opening but promises world-class
dining and a place of refuge for park
visitors who grow tired of the traffic
outside near the front of the Disneyland
Park on the second flow of the Main
Street firehouse Walt arraigned for the
construction of a special apartment for
himself and his family to stay to this
day a light remains lit in the window as
a tribute to him there are now
Disneyland parks operating in Tokyo
Paris Hong Kong and Shanghai bringing
Walt vision to the rest of the world
this also means that the Sun is always
shining on at least one Disney park oh
and there is a basketball court
inside the Matterhorn at Disneyland
California but there's also a dark side
to Disneyland numerous people have died
at Disney parks
one such powering case occurred in 1966
when a teenager was killed whilst
attempting to sneak into Disneyland by
climbing onto the monorail track he was
struck by the train and dragged 12
meters down the track despite a security
guard yelling at him the whole time to
stop in fact stuff at the Haunted
Mansion rides at Disney parks have to be
constantly on the lookout for people
dumping Ash
strangely having one's ashes scattered
on the ride is a popular request
obviously Disney aren't overly pleased
about the trend in 1970 Yippies took
over Tom Sawyer island at Disneyland to
stage a smoking to protest Disneyland
dress code Disney was not amused they
closed a park early and called in the
riot police ever the innovator in 1937
Walt Disney pioneered the use of a new
type of camera for filming animation one
which allowed for greater depth to
reinforce the illusion of the action on
screen occurring in three dimensions
the result was the multi-plane camera
first tested in one of Disney's Silly
Symphonies shorts before being used in
the filming of Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs the success of Snow White spawned
what would be remembered as the Golden
Age of animation as Walt Disney gained
the financial stability and public
confidence necessary to produce more
films destined to become classics like
Pinocchio and Fantasia
the California Institute of the art was
the brainchild of Walt Disney who
dreamed of a School for the Performing
and visual arts where fellow artists
could learn from and encourage one
another the staggering list of
noteworthy Cal arts alumni include
animation legends arlene klasky tim
burton lauren faust and one who many
consider to be walt disney's spiritual
successor John Lasseter the acting chief
creative officer of Pixar and Walt
Disney Animation Studios to date Walt
Disney has received the most Oscars out
of any multiple Oscar recipient holding
22 of the prestigious awards for his
creative work he also holds the record
for most Academy Award nominations with
59 nominations to his credit his last
Academy Award was granted posthumously 7
of Walt Disney's films have been deemed
so culturally significant to the United
States that they have been selected for
preservation by the National Film
Preservation Board of the Library of
Congress among their numbers are Mary
Poppins Steamboat Willie and Bambi
decades of smoking eventually caught up
with Walt on November the 11th of 1966
when doctors discovered a wall
sighs l'm on his left lung by the time
it was discovered the tumor had
metastasized prompting the lungs removal
he died on December the 15th 1966 of
acute circulatory collapse caused by the
lung cancer rumors persist that Disney
wasn't actually cremated as claimed by
his family but instead had his body
cryogenically frozen and tucked away for
safekeeping
beneath the Pirates of the Caribbean
ride at Disneyland California presumably
to be resuscitated at a later date
once medical technology has progressed
sufficiently perhaps Tomorrowland was
simply a conceptual testing ground for
living in the future thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you